that you ladies are addicted like we are
here to the hit Netflix dating show love
is blind
yep just started completely addicted
okay I'm not getting married I didn't
know about you you're not ever getting
married again
well the show ended 15 months ago so
fans want to know where is the cast now
after the show perhaps I had a really
tough time you know kind of take some
time for myself and get through therapy
and stuff like that
Jessica says professional help and a
cross-country move with her wine
drinking pump helped her get ready to
face mark for the first time since
leaving him at the altar I'm not gonna
apologize to myself because I'm not
actually sorry
only et was behind the scenes of the
reunion dropping Thursday on Netflix and
guess what mark is still be mark like
Who I am today is because of like what
we did and whatever you if you ever need
something like don't hesitate to call
but not everyone was so quick to forgive
Jessica's sometimes messy behavior fans
watched as Jessica seemed to flirt with
Amber's man Barnett watching it back it
really looks like you know I was going
after her guy and I wanted to just let
her know that's not necessarily exactly
what was going on nothing I'll ever
break the bond okay I came in today like
definitely knowing that I owed them both
an apology you accept her
do hair no I don't particularly care how
she feels about it not everybody is
gonna let you just flirt with death oh
man I'm just saying that's not okay
people will call you out and remember
the most explosive fight of the season I
don't deal with women like yo diamond
was blindsided by Carlton's revelation
that he's bisexual the blow-up at the
pool I totally disrespected her so I
have to apologize to see you again
because I feel like I am apologizing
like daily that's how bad I feel about
it
this is why I don't deal with like you I
would never tell the way nobody caught
me I'm not lame if you want to be with
me and down with me you should always
have my back and you should always be
expect me I'm trying to take her on a
date the answer is no right now okay
moving on to fan favorites Cameron and
Lauren they were the first to fall for
each other kiss your bride now could
they be first to have a baby I mean my
fraternal instincts yeah see good for
them and by the way get ready Cameron
and Lauren lovers because we're about to
put them to work it's our love is blind
take over this Thursday they will guest
co-host and so will fan favorites Damien
and Gigi by the way are those two
officially back together don't worry
we'll find out